can with c-span founder guru eminence
Brian lamb Brian thanks for sitting down
with us you bet Nick Brian in 2003 we
named you one of our 35 heroes of
freedom to celebrate our 35th
anniversary and I'll just catch up the
viewers with what we wrote Brian lamb
the great stone face of c-span has
produced more must-see TV than anyone
else in the history of the medium
there's no reason to pick a favorite
among the likes of booknotes Washington
journal and all the other c-span fair
but his greatest contribution may well
be as first turning a surveillance
camera on the den of iniquity known as
the US House of Representatives I don't
stand by that those are your words right
what are the issues what are what are
the key issues for you today in terms of
the media landscape and regulation of
media well let me just say that the all
it's still to this day it's still and
this is not regulation but it's still
how much capacity is out there for your
programming to be seen in other words
c-span is not universally all three
channels aren't University shown on
every platform because there's always it
seems like there's always some kind of a
shortage out there of space it's there's
no shortage yet on the internet when it
comes to regulation the industry and I
don't speak ever for the cable industry
the industry always has issues because
if you look at law as it is passed it's
always kind of a jury-rigged process
it's like thirty percent over here and
you can have X number of radio stations
and you can't do this and can't do that
so there's always going to be an issue I
mean that's that's just the way that
place is organized with do you think
political discourse is particularly to
base now or angry or vitriolic or is it
same old same old I think what's going
on in talk is fabulous the hard right to
hard left I don't care what it is it's
it's it's stimulating a lot of people to
think some people aren't thinking they
have a point of view that's fine they've
always had that but we act like this is
all new I mean remember when they used
to strap guns to their belts and go into
the house of representatives and
challenge one another to a duel this is
pretty tame stuff who are your political
if you
do you have political heroes no why not
well you know we've taken the money I
have them do you actually not have them
or are you you don't want to talk about
I don't have you know I I you know
people that watches so filled with hate
anger people that watch us think we're
up here thinking about we have an agenda
no agenda my only agenda has ever been
in politics I mean I've gone through
different stages in my life I thought I
knew what I was talking about but my
only agenda is how are you going to pay
for this I don't care what you spend it
on that's a decision that the process
very carefully can make or not so
carefully it's where's the money coming
from its to my money is the biggest
issue in the United States and the debt
and that whole issue and that's going to
be what kills us do you have a politics
know if so if somebody sifted through we
got like a supercomputer and sift
through all the program with c-span and
they wouldn't be able to draw a pattern
which is Brian lamb secret politics t
have at it yeah that'd be fascinating
but it wasting money it would be
tremendous I mean everybody go oh wow
now what do I do with it what what about
your hometown does that inform or how
does that inform who you are and what
you do at Indiana at the time used to
have a rule that if you work for state
government the party in power got two
percent of your income but get out like
what is I mean even the Mafia doesn't do
that mm-hmm well they don't do it
anymore but I really got educated about
politics from my father who was a
wholesale beer distributor required a
license from the state would pay money
to the Democrat running and the
Republican running and then get furious
when the winter wouldn't do what he
wanted him to do and he needed a license
and he loved the fact that he knew the
Chairman to the Alcoholic Beverage
Commission and he was his personal
friend and it goes on and on i saw it i
mean he'd take him to football games
with him he was a friend of our families
and all that stuff and
worked when the governor was elected to
get the person that they wanted in as
the chairman of the alcoholic beverage
Commission it's in a microcosm exactly
what we have all over the country and I
said to myself you know there's
something wrong with it is your demeanor
than is that like the taking a kind of
Midwestern reserved to the nth degree
yes you don't really believe that do you
know if you could put on a different
mask right now what would it be or if
you could if you could live your life
over again obviously you've you know
you've really I'm delivered on your
early promise I shots is to lift it over
again I you know if I had to live over
again I'd be a drummer and full time on
the road baby yeah what kind of music
would you play or will you or do you
also like that's not important I would
be the backup band for Merle Haggard or
Willie Nelson but either one and if I
couldn't do that i'd be the roadie with
brenda lee well i think we will leave it
on that note I want to thank Brian lamb
of c-span for taking time to talk to
reason TV today I'm Nick Gillespie thank
you Brian and thank you next
you